- [Voiceover] Let's do some examples
of the writing expressions
with variables exercise.
So it says "Write an expression
to represent 11 more than a."
Well you could just have a
but if you want 11 more than a,
you would wanna add 11
so you could write that as a plus 11.
You could also write that as 11 plus a.
Both of them would be 11 more than a.
So let's check our answer here.
We got it right.
Let's do a few more of these.
"Write an expression to represent the sum
of d and 9."
So the sum of d and 9,
that means you're gonna add d and 9.
So I could write that as d plus 9
or I could write that as 9 plus d.
And check our answer.
Got that right.
Let's do a few more of these.
"Write an expression to
represent j minus 15."
Well, I could just write
it with math symbols
instead of writing the word minus.
Instead of writing M-I-N-U-S,
I could write j minus 15.
And then I check my answer.
Got it right.
Let's do a few more of these.
This is a lot of fun.
"Write an expression to
represent 7 times r."
There's a couple ways I could do it.
I could use this little
dot right over here,
do 7 times r like that.
That would be correct.
I could literally just write 7r.
If I just wrote 7r that would also count.
Let me check my answer.
That's right.
Let me do a couple of other of these
just so you can see that I could've
just done 10 and this is not a decimal,
it sits a little bit
higher than a decimal.
It's multiplication and the reason why
once you start doing
algebra, you use this symbol
instead of that kind of
cross for multiplication
is that x-looking thing
gets confused with x
when you're using x as a variable
so that's why this is a lot more useful.
So we wanna write 10 times u,
10 times u, let's check our answer.
We got it right.
Let's do one more.
"Write an expression to
represent 8 divided by d."
So we could write it as
8 and then I could write
a slash like that, 8 divided by d.
And there you go.
This is 8 divided by d.
Let me check, let me check the answer.
I'll do one more of these.
Oh, it's 6 divided by b.
Alright, same thing.
So 6, I could use this
tool right over here.
It does the same thing
as if I were to press the backslash.
So 6 divided by b.
Check my answer.
We got it right.